later procurement which the labor
control
said was a benchmark for procurement
[Music]
mr speaker let's be clear what these
texts
show the prime minister was lobbied by a
wealthy businessman and a close friend
for a change in the tax rules tax rules
the prime minister responded i'll fix it
then after a discussion with the
chancellor who everybody seems to be
lobbying these days
the prime minister texted his friend to
say it's fixed
how many other people with the prime
minister's personal number
has he given preferential treatment to
prime minister
mr speaker i i recall the right
honourable gentleman
uh at the time uh saying that we should
do everything
uh that we could to uh get more
ventilators and and indeed uh he he
congratulated the
the rollout of the event he said that he
said that well done to everybody
involved
for the ventilator challenge let's
remind the house what we were facing
in march last year mr speaker which was
we had a new virus
which was capable of killing people in
ways that we didn't understand the only
way to help them
uh in extremists was to intubate them
and put them on ventilation
we had 9 000 ventilators in this country
mr speaker
we secured 22 000 as a result of that
ventilator challenge
i think it was entirely the right thing
to do to work with all potential
all potential makers of ventilators at
that time mr speaker
and by the way so does the former leader
of the labour party a man to whom i
think he should listen
tony blair
[Music]
mr speaker i'm surprised the prime
minister brings out former leaders since
it's his
former leader his friend i think dave
who's at the heart of
uh much of this and i acknowledge
thousands of businesses stepped up
during the pandemic that was a good
thing
and we celebrate that the difference is
they didn't all have the chance
to text the prime minister ask him to
fix the tax situation
in exchange for doing that that's the
difference at the heart of this scandal
are people's jobs and wasted taxpayers
money
take for example take for example the
thousands of jobs
at liberty steel that are on the line
in hartlepool in rotherham and elsewhere
following the collapse of greenville
capital
the prime minister hasn't fixed that in
fact he's done nothing to help steel
workers
is it now quite literally one rule for
those that got the prime minister's
phone number another for everybody else
i minister mr speaker uh he calls it a
scandal
he voted uh for the changes uh that we
brought in
our ventilator he called our ventilator
challenge an outstanding success and i
think he was completely right
this is a government that gets on and uh
delivers for people
uh in distress and and delivers for the
other people's priorities and yes
uh yes of course uh i'm i'm concerned
for the families of steel workers uh up
and down the up and down the country
that's why the business secretary has
been meeting with
uh the unions and with the management of
liberty steel repeatedly over the last
few days but we believe in british steel
uh mr speaker it was under
under the labor uh last labour
government that jobs in steel
fell by more than 50 and output fell by
more than 50
we've now got a 5 million ton pipeline
of british steel uh with our massive
infrastructure investments and we intend
to use our new freedoms under brexit to
make sure that procurement goes to
british companies mr speaker
dear starbucks well he says we believe
in british too but do something
i have to say to the prime minister
still work because waking up this
morning
we'll find it deeply offensive to hear
the prime minister boasting to his
friends that
he's the first lord of the treasury and
we can give you the backing we need
he won't give the steel workers the
backing that they need
mr speaker this shows once again that
favors
privileged access tax breaks for mates
they're the now they're the main
currency of this conservative government
and if that's not the case prime
minister can the prime minister tell me
if one of the three million
self-employed people
who've been excluded from government
support for over a year
and now face bankruptcy if they text the
prime minister to ask for a tax break
so they can survive would he change the
rules for them too
mr speaker we've given uh this
government i should say has
supported the self-employed with more
than 14 billion pounds
throughout the pandemic and uh we and
that's as part of
a vast package of support for
for jobs and livelihoods across the
country we continue to do
everything it takes and i think that he
should take back what he said
about the ventilator challenge he
attacks the vent attempt ventilator
challenge now
our efforts our efforts to get more
ventilators at a very very difficult
time
for this country in the same way mr
speaker by the way in which he
opportunistically
attacked the vaccine task force at a
critical moment uh which he will which
he will recall
mr speaker we take the tough decisions
that are necessary
to protect the people of this country
and get things done
mr speaker if i had to correct the prime
minister for everything he gets wrong
i'd be here all day
i take it i take it that's a no as an
answer the question in relation to the
three million
and there we have it an open door but
for those with the prime minister's
number
a closed door to the three million
what this shows once again is the extent
of the sleaze and cronyism
that's at the heart of his conservative
government let me try another way
prime minister let me try another way if
an nhs
nurse if an nhs nurse prime minister
who's been working on the front line
during the pandemic
had the prime minister's phone number
would they get the pay rise they so
obviously
deserve mr speaker i'm proud of what
this government has done to support the
nhs
throughout the pandemic uh with record
investments
and uh with another 92 billion that we
put in
uh to support the nhs throughout the
pandemic and what we're doing to help
nurses as he knows
is last year putting in the bursary of
five thousand pounds
plus the three thousand pounds on top to
help them with training
and the costs of child care uh twelve
point a twelve point eight percent
increase on starting salary uh just uh
in the last
uh couple of years mr speaker and uh
above all
this is the government that is helping
nurses and helping the profession
by recruiting more than ever before and
where there are again if there are
already 50
000 more people in the nhs this year
than there were last year
mr speaker and 10 600 more nurses
that's what i'd say uh to many of the
nurses that i've talked to in the last
few days and weeks and we will continue
to back them to the hilt
if the prime has been talking to the nhs
frontline he'd know just how insulted
they are
by his paper after everything they've
put in in the last year
they didn't get a text from the prime
minister they got a kick in the teeth
mr speaker there's a pattern to this
government
the prime minister is fixing tax breaks
for his friends
the chancellor is pushing the treasury
to help lex greensville
the health sector is meeting greenself
for drinks
and david cameron's texting anybody will
reply
every day every day there are new
allegations about this conservative
government
dodgy ppe deals tax breaks for their
mates
the health secretary owns shares in a
company delivering nhs services
sleaze sleaze sleaze
and it's all on his watch
with this scandal now firmly centered on
him
how on earth does he expect people to
believe that he is the person
to clean this mess up
i'll tell you why because this i'll tell
you why this government is
is doing the right thing at the right
time because the difference between uh
us and the labour party is is i'm afraid
uh
staringly obvious and we get on uh with
taking the tough decisions
uh to protect the people of this country
and to take our country forward
uniting 11. we we take the tough
decisions to procure
thousands tens of thousands of
ventilators in record time which
apparently he now
opposes and we we put we put forward
tougher sentences
for rapists and violent criminals mr
speaker which he then opposes
on a three-line whip uh mr speaker
and we stick up we take tough decisions
to stick up for the fans
to stick up for the fans of our national
game captain hindsight
snipes continually from the sidelines
this government
gets on with delivering on the people's
priorities mr speaker
philip davis thank you mr speaker back
in 2019 the government gave the labour
council in bradford
hundreds of thousands of pounds to carry
out a feasibility study
for shipley eastern bypass it was due to
report in the autumn of 2019
they put it back to april 2020 and yet a
year on from that there is still no sign
of it
please will the prime minister intervene
to ensure this vital infrastructure
project is delivered
and will meet with me and our honorable
friend the member for keithley
to see how we can progress our campaign
to break away our constituencies
from bradford council to set up a truly
local
unitary authority to deliver for our
constituents
prime minister mr speaker on the
on on the second point i uh i'm sure the
relevant
uh minister would be happy to meet him
to consult him uh but on
on his point about the the shipley
bypass uh the matter is currently with
bradford
uh council and i suggest that that labor
control grants for the example many
conservative uh controlled uh councils
and deliver
uh that essential infrastructure project
on time
creating jobs and opportunities for his
constituents
let's go to the leader of the snp ian
blackford ian
and thank you mr speaker and can i
associate myself with the
remarks of the prime minister and the
leader of the opposition
on both the queen's 95th birthday and
the justice that we've now seen in the
george floyd case
mr speaker this morning's revelations
surrounding the prime minister's
interference and covert contracts
are incredibly serious whether it's cash
for questions in the 90s
or text for contracts during this
pandemic
people know this is the same old story
this is how the tories do government the
prime minister
is at the very heart of this scandal
mr speaker well the prime minister
revealed today
how many more coveted contracts he
personally fixed
and if he has nothing to hide will they
publish all personal exchanges on these
contracts
before the end of the day prime minister
mr speaker of course
there's absolutely nothing that uh uh to
conceal about this and i'm happy to uh
to share all the details with the houses
indeed i've shared them
uh with my uh with my officials
immediately
uh mr speaker and it's thanks to that
immediate action
uh that we've been able to roll out and
not just of the to deal with the
vaccinator uh back the ventilator
uh challenge but also uh to help the
people of the whole
uh united kingdom uh to get access uh in
record times
uh to the vaccines on which we all
depend uh and i think what the people of
this kind
and the same goes for for rolling out
ppe mr speaker we've had to work
at incredible speed and i think the
people of this country understand
uh that is sometimes necessary uh to act
decisively to get things done
let's go back to in blackfoot ian
if the prime minister says there's
nothing to see here publish them
let us all see them let's have that
transparency because frankly
his excuses just don't stack up last
march
the prime minister and the chancellor
had all the time in the world
to fix contracts for the cosy club of
friends and tory donors
but didn't have any time to support the
millions of self-employed
those three million people didn't have a
david cameron
or a james dyson to text the prime
minister for them
they were on their own and they were
left behind by this prime minister
this story text for contract scandal is
growing more and more serious with every
revelation
the prime minister was eager to initiate
an enquiry into his predecessor david
cameron
but he is quick to commit to a public
and comprehensive inquiry
into himself and his own government
politics well uh mr speaker
he says we we had all the uh the time in
the world
in fact as the house will recall uh at
the end of march
last year the uh the pandemic was taking
off very fast and we had to act
uh very fast as i think uh people up and
down this country
understand and uh i i thought that uh
his dog
uh just made a more sensible
contribution
just now than he did fed jones
thank you thank you mr speaker farmers
farmers in bracket and radlesha have
worked entirely tirelessly
to give us world-class british food
throughout the pandemic
in return the welsh labour and liberal
democrat government have given them
a slap in the face with their nitrate
vulnerable zone policy which will do
nothing for water quality and ignores
the water companies dumping thousands of
tons of sewage
into our rivers mr speaker does the
prime minister agree with me
that this demonstrates welsh labour's
absolute contempt for rural areas like
mine
[Music]
yes she is entirely right mr speaker
because agriculture is of course
uh devolved in uh in wales and
uh if people want to send a clear signal
and
they want change in the way farmers are
treated in wales and i hope they will
vote conservative
in the welsh assembly elections in just
two weeks time will vote for a party
that actually champions agriculture and
believes in it
let's go to sir jeffrey donaldson sir
jeffrey
prime minister i was proud to put on the
uniform of the crown
and to serve with tens of thousands of
men and women
from our armed forces and our police in
protecting the entire community
in northern ireland from the ravages of
terrorism
during our troubled past the prime
minister gave a commitment in his
election manifesto
to introduce legislation to protect
those
men and women from vexatious
prosecutions
will the prime minister stand by and
honor
that commitment prime minister
i thank my right honorable i thank the
right honourable gentleman very much for
uh first of all for his service and
uh i i know that the house will agree
and uh i want to say i want to put on
record by the way mr speaker my thanks
to the
uh the former minister uh for uh for
veterans for all the
uh that he did uh to help with uh
improving the lot of
veterans across our country uh and we
have protected
uh many veterans with the overseas
operations bill there is more to be done
as he rightly says in the case of uh
veterans
uh in northern of the northern ireland
conflict and
we will be uh bringing forward further
measures in due course
let's go chewie and leave it ian
thank you mr speaker since 2019 blythe
valley has benefited
from significant investment for leveling
up including the towns fund the future
high streets fund
and the reinstatement of the rail line
we know now that blythe will be the home
of the uk's first gigafactory developed
by british folds
further demonstrating the commitment to
build back better
can i congratulate my friend on his
drive and commitment
to help in areas which have been
neglected for so long
and ask him to assure the house that he
will do all that he can
to help those areas realize their full
potential
and i would like to offer my right
honourable friend an open invitation to
visit this fabulous constituency of
blyth valley
where i'm sure he will receive a very
warm welcome
prime minister i i thank my honorable
friend very much and
it was only lately that he and i stood
on the the seafront uh
by then we looked out at some of the
incredible wind farms and
just the harbingers the prelude of the
huge dogger bank uh wind farms
uh that are going to be built in the uh
in the north sea i'm delighted that uh a
gig of
gigafactory for batteries is being uh
established in
in blythe valley and uh thanks to his
help and his uh
and his leadership uh we are seeing
blythe valley and many other parts of
of the of the northeast at the forefront
of the green
industrial revolution driving delivering
high wage
uh and uh high-skilled jobs across our
country
good jobs thank you mr speaker
last week hundreds of gmb gas engineers
were sacked
who are refusing to sign new contracts
expecting them
to work harder and get paid less
fire and rehire abusers by rogue
employees are spreading through
workplaces like a virus the government
has called the practice
unacceptable and bully-boy tactics but
refused to take action
to ban it i'm giving the prime minister
the chance to show us
all where he stands will he commit here
and now
to include proposals to end the shameful
and
immoral practice of fire and rehire in
next month's
queen speech yes or no prime minister
i i re repeat what i have said about
that practice and if she'd be kind
enough
uh to send me uh particular details
about the case
uh that she mentioned she raises i will
be happy to have it
to take it up dr bensberg
thank you uh mr speaker access to super
fast broadband
is critical in today's society but many
people living in running medium
weighbridge
can't access it and while this question
is essential viewing
my constituents may struggle to watch it
streaming at home this evening
if someone else is catching up on the
mattress masterchef final
does my right animal friend share my
ambition that everyone in running medium
weighbridge should have access to super
fast broadband
just as every house should have access
to water and electricity
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend and he's entirely right and
that's why uh we've massively
accelerated the
uh the rollout of gigabit broadband
superfast proper and gigabit broadband
and coverage uh of a reliable gigabit
broadband was just nine percent
uh when this government took over it
will be sixty percent
by uh the end of this year and we're
driving it up across
the whole country uh uniting and
leveling up and unleashing the potential
of the entire of the uk
thank you day after day we see
more corruption come to light yet day
after day i speak to
more desperate constituents who are
excluded
from this government's support people
who've lost livelihoods homes
businesses built up over the years and
been unable to put
food on their table and yet it seems all
they needed
was the prime minister of chancellor's
phone number frankly
i'm ashamed on behalf of this country
so will the prime minister and
chancellor now take the calls of my
constituents
in cardiff north and meet with me and
them
to discuss how they can rebuild their
lives after losing
so much uh mr speaker i'm proud
of the roll out of the ventilators
uh 30 000 that we delivered from scratch
i'm proud of it
i'm proud of the decisions uh that we
took i'm proud of what we did
criticized uh by the labour party uh to
roll out vaccines
uh at record speed i'm proud of what we
did to support the people
of this country throughout the pandemic
with an overall package of 407
billion pounds to support people in this
country and we this country will bounce
back all the better
and all the stronger because of the
strong economy
that we ensured that this country had
going in to the crisis which would have
been
impossible mr speaker under a labor
government and that is what
she should tell her constituents
uh mr speaker i was deeply concerned at
the weekend
following reports in the sunday express
that the statue of the great united
states president ronald reagan
which once stood in grosvenor square has
been removed
and remains out of public sight i know
the prime minister will agree with me
that president reagan
was a true friend to the united kingdom
who alongside margaret thatcher
ended the cold war and supported britain
during the liberation
of the falkland islands now that our
american friends have moved to a new
embassy in wandsworth
would the prime minister agree with me
that president reagan's statue should be
moved
to a more prominent location on
parliament square so that visitors
from home and across the globe can honor
this remarkable man
prime minister did you notice mr speaker
how
uh the bench's opposite recoiled uh the
idea of the recapture of the falkland
eyes have
when you've just heard an honourable
member say that she was ashamed of her
country
mr speaker it is no wonder that people
take
that kind of that kind of attitude i
think that he's entirely right in what
he says
about president uh reagan i think he was
a very distinguished uh president it's
not up to me uh to install a statue for
him i think that's for the greater
london
authority i think he has to appeal to
the current uh mayor of london or let's
hope
uh there's a new one uh to do justice uh
to the memory of ronald reagan
let's go to dr philippa whitford
philippa
thank you very much mr speaker polio a
disease that kills
and maims children has been eliminated
in all but one region of the world
due to the incredible work of the global
polio eradication initiative
in 2019 the uk international development
secretary
pledged 400 million pounds to the
program
as he said to do otherwise would risk a
return to thousands of new polio cases
every year so will the prime minister
now reassure the house
that he will honor that commitment
yes mr speaker the global polio
eradication initiative uh has been
backed by 1.37
billion pounds in uk aid since 1995
and as she rightly says there are many
proud successes of that program and
polio
across the planet very very largely
thanks to
uh the help of the british taxpayer has
been
uh almost eliminated let's go to
sakubati second thank you mr speaker i'm
pleased that common sense has prevailed
and that all
six english clubs have now committed to
withdrawing from the european super
league
does my right on girlfriend agree that
if we are to protect the beautiful game
further
football clubs must put fans at the
heart of their decision making
yes i do mr speaker and i think that one
of the
uh most worrying features about the
european super league proposals is that
they would have taken
clubs that uh take their names uh from
uh great famous uh british towns
uh and cities uh english times and
cities and uh and turned them just into
global
uh brands with no relation to the fans
to the communities
uh that gave them life and that uh give
them the most love and
support and that was in my view totally
wrong say nothing of the
of the lack of competition and uh it's
entirely right that
uh my honourable friend the member for
chatterman elseville
uh will do a root and branch uh
investigation uh into
uh the governance of football and into
what we can do to promote
the role of fans in that governance i'm
brown
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will be aware that opinion polls
continue to show a majority in favor of
scottish independence
does he agree that one fact is the fact
we've been lumbered with a prime
minister who thinks
a pound spent in croydon is of more
value to the country than a pound spent
strathclyde
prime minister mr speaker i think what
the i think what the people of scotland
uh need is a a government administration
in scotland uh that spends uh the
taxpayers money in scotland better and
more wisely because the results
i'm afraid of the scottish nationalist
party are dismal uh they're failing on
education
uh they're failing on crime uh they're
failing uh on their taxation policies mr
speaker
and no wonder all they can talk about is
another
irresponsible referendum of breaking up
this country
thank you mr speaker recycling is one
way in which we could all
individually tackle the climate crisis
uh will he join me in congratulating
west sussex county council on recycling
53
of their household waste a level that's
almost double that
of neighboring brighton council
my honourable pen draws attention to a
very valuable and important point which
is across the country mr speaker these
conservative councils
that keep your council tax low uh uh
overwhelmingly
uh and deliver better services uh such
as
uh such as recycling and uh we and and
he's absolutely right
uh to lord uh the efforts of the
conservative
lead council in in west sussex mr
speaker
let's go to colton carl
the recent conservative party political
broadcast
the home secretary claimed that only
conservative police and crime
commissioners are responsible for
increasing police officer numbers
yet homicides policing crime
commissioner keith hunter
has put well over 500 additional
officers on our streets since 2016
the largest proportionate increase in
the country
and was doing so well before the
government pledged
to reverse their own cuts so will the
prime minister take this opportunity
to do the decent thing correct the
record
and congratulate keith hunter from
taking homicide police
from the worst performing force to one
of the best in his time
as police and crime commissioner
prime minister uh well uh mr speaker
uh i'm i'm i'm afraid i'm i don't wish
to be uh
to sound um you know like a stickler for
uh for accuracy here mr speaker but
since uh
since becoming homicides pcc which is my
normal position mr speaker as you as you
know
uh since becoming homicide pcc in 2016
the force has recruited 434 officers
uh of these 129 have been recruited as
part of the government's uh 20 000
driver mr hunter himself praised uh the
government's
police recruitment strategy saying the
government's her
target had lifted officers numbers in
homicide above
2000. so i think it'd be fair to say uh
that uh mr hunter's efforts
uh uh however laudable uh they may be
would have been impossible without the
determination of this government to
recruit more police officers
and put them out on the street
thank you mr speaker when my right
honorable friend
visited the west midlands earlier this
week to meet with our brilliant mayor
andy street
was he aware that the mayor has
increased by sevenfold
the investment in transport and we now
have 108
new shiny carriages for the cross city
line what advice does my right
honourable friend
have for my constituents in the royal
town of southern coalfield
on may the 6th ball's on the penalty
spot come on
mr speaker uh i i i well
and not only uh not only is he uh
rolling out uh 50 uh new stations mr
speaker but 150 miles more
of track uh linking up uh communities
across
uh the west midlands delivering job
opportunities delivering growth
delivering hope
for the west midlands and that's why i
think the people of the west middle
should vote for another term for mayor
andy street
let's bring in the goalkeeper john
speller
i should i shall decline that invitation
as a west midlands voter
but the prime minister the prime
minister earlier said he would use new
freedoms to ensure that they buy british
steel
and over the last year the difficulties
with ppe provision and vaccine
production
has demonstrated very clearly the risk
of neglecting british productive
production capacity let alone the impact
on the prosperity and leveling up
agendas
so prime minister will you now instruct
government ministers
civil servants and other public bodies
that when purchasing goods
and services they must buy british first
yeah prime minister yes of course mr
speaker and look at what we're achieving
because since the ppe crisis big assets
the pandemic began
we've turned things right so in that
we've procured
uh 32 billion items of ppe and 85
of it can now be made in this country
which was completely impossible
uh before the pandemic began look at
what's happening on on on vaccines where
we've got the valniva factory
in uh in scotland we've got novavax in t
side which is going to be absolutely
indispensable
for our future success and those
those investments will not only help us
to
protect our country against pandemics
for the future
they will help us to drive jobs and
prosperity for the long term
across the whole of the uk
order i would like to update the house
on some news from the house of lords
i'm informed that lord mack fall lord
mcfaul of oldham
has been successfully elected to the
position of lord speaker
i have known john mike falls since i was
elected the mp for troll in 1997
and you couldn't find a nicer kind or a
more welcoming politician
not only so uh the speaker paying
tribute to
uh john mcfall uh the uh former
financial expert on the labour benches
who's been chosen to take over from
norman fowler as the speaker
in the lords uh prime minister began uh
question
time uh by uh welcoming the verdicts
of guilty on uh derek chovin for the
death of
george floyd and also commending the
decision
of the collapse basically which led to
the collapse of the european
super league but sleaze
was once again the main item of currency
between uh the prime minister and his
opposite numbers on the opposition
benches and with me is our presidential
beth rigby
so sleaze yes adam this is uh
what kirschdammer went on today was this
story that emerged in the bbc this
morning about sir james dyson you'll
know him
as the man who makes all of our hoovers
uh he was asked to help
uh with the ventilator project you
remember last year when there was that
huge
shortage uh he'd written uh
to the treasury seeking assurances that
if his staff came here to pay
uh to help with the ventilation project
they wouldn't have to pay
more tax he didn't get an answer he
texted the prime minister directly
the prime minister said he would fix it
so that's the nub of the actual detail
of the story now actually they didn't
end up they didn't end up
surprised you're right they didn't end
up supplying the the
ventilators uh sakir stama
today has gone in on this saying that
this is another example
of tory's sleaze that it shows that if
you've got the pm's
phone number that you can get direct
access to him
that it's an open door for billionaires
it's a closed shot for
nurses wanting pay rises uh and the
prime minister
and responses said he makes absolutely
no apology for doing everything he could
to secure ventilators
for people of this country and to save
lives so on the actual substance of the
detail of
of what went on the prime minister hit
him back
uh quite ferociously actually and seemed
quite irritated
uh by it in the chamber but sarkistan
was obviously
lighted on the fact that sleaze and tory
sleeves
is something politically that he wants
to push should we have a listen to one
of the exchanges
there's a pattern to this government
the prime minister is fixing tax breaks
for his friends
the chancellor is pushing the treasury
to help lex greensville
the health sector is meeting greenself
for drinks
and david cameron's texting anybody will
reply
every day every day there are new
allegations about this conservative
government
dodgy ppe deals tax breaks for their
mates
the health secretary owns shares in a
company delivering nhs services
sleaze sleaze sleaze
and it's all on his watch
with this scandal now firmly centered on
him
how on earth does he expect people to
believe that he is the person
to clean this mess up
i'll tell you why because this i'll tell
you why this government is
is doing the right thing at the right
time because the difference between uh
us and the labour party is is i'm afraid
uh
staringly obvious and we get on with
taking the tough decisions
uh to protect the people of this country
and to take our country forward
uniting 11. we we take the tough
decisions to procure
thousands tens of thousands of
ventilators in record time which
apparently he now
opposes are we we put we put forward
tougher sentences
for rapists uh and violent criminals mr
speaker which he then opposes
on a three-line whip uh mr speaker
and we stick up we take tough decisions
to stick up for the fans
to stick up for the fans of our national
game captain hindsight
snipes continually from the sidelines
this government
gets on with delivering on the people's
priorities mr speaker
[Applause]
and uh beth it has to be said the
current leader of the labour party not
really helped by comments from a
previous leader at the labour party no
well that's right uh tony blair was
asked about this this morning and he
said he couldn't really get that
worked up or agitated he didn't really
see
this particular issue as a problem in
this particular circumstances in that
james dyson asked the prime minister
from some reassurances
he gave those as you said he didn't make
any financial gain from it in fact the
ventilators
in the end uh meant that that they were
they didn't need to be used so
in terms of the specifics of the story
uh it doesn't seem to be a huge scandal
but the principle labour would argue
is that there is these issues about
direct access to politicians it's not
about
cameron it goes right to the johnson
government too and that's
the big question that they will want to
push it's a session of prime minister's
questions beth that may be best
remembered for that barking dog
on ian blackford's link uh i can reveal
talkwall crichton
uh scottish correspondent has reporting
that the barking dog is called
maisy there you go well thank you very
much indeed and that's all
from us here in westminster today on uh
prime minister's questions uh
all that politics back tomorrow but
we're going to go
in a moment for more on george floyd's
death as america wakes up the morning
after those convictions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you